stand hey buddy
hey hey Morris
police moris police hey
buddy
hey Morris police hey
bud you
good
huh do you know where you are right
now hey Tomy homie go
home go hom go home
homie hey don't lose your phone go home
go home what's your
name do Dove
Dave how much have you had to drink Dave
you
Fu time to
go yeah I see
that how about you get out of the car
for me
okay let's let's get out of the car
Dave got to make sure you're okay okay
you don't look very good right
now you can't even
talk
Come On Dave let's get out of the
car hey Dave I'm I asking you to get out
of the car
okay I'll tell you right now you're good
to go I'm good to go I'm not no you
don't make those you don't get to make
that decision I do I'm telling
you
you are
[Music]
okay well I have to make sure you don't
get to make those decisions Dave okay if
I see that you're okay to drive then you
can go but right now we're not at that
point going anywhere we're going
anywhere okay I need you to get out of
the car for me okay or you can go to
jail for
[Applause]
obstructing what instructing a peace
officer this is now an investigation
okay and you're obstructing my
investigation I'm trying to save you not
to go to jail okay so how about if we
step out of the car
the more Cooperative you are the more
the faster you get to go home okay I'm
tell you we're not going to jail for any
reason whatsoever why is
that who we are I have no idea who you
are yes you do no I really
don't I have never seen you in my life
yes so is your name Dave no what is your
name he told me your name was Dave
yeah or something on the lines of that
or Dove you actually said Dove Dove and
D so your name is Doug Doug
D
jve yes we are all on the
same no whatever your name is I need you
to get out of the car now or you're
going to go to jail for
obstructing this who you are so how
about let's hop out don't be reaching
looking back for anything let's get out
of the car okay out of the car oh get
out of the car thank you okay now come
back over here to my front of my squad
car
okay what oh you're passed out on the
driver seat of your car so I need to
make sure you're okay to drive just
stand right there you're good you don't
have to do anything
man
anyad I'd like to see all the
offic whoever's
there
okay Doug is that your
name right here you you're looking
at I
no well it sounds like you're under the
influence so here's the thing I'm going
to ask you do you feel sobriety
test you're not going to do
it I can't just check your eyes just
make sure you're okay okay if I offered
you a PBT affordable breath test would
you want to submit a breath sample no
okay now here's what I'm going to have
to do place your hands behind your back
you're going to be rest for
DOI
it's your cell phone in the
truck wallet in the
truck
[Music]
okay I got I got his
ke Douglas go over to the slad car back
here
okay don't fall over let's go this
way
left or
right are you good you're falling all
over hop in the car over
here go and take take a
seat swing your leg
in go the other side can't go the other
side and
back
you good
Doug talk to me you good lock
up you want to sleep it off is that what
your plan is do you need an
ambulance yes
no
okay
KCK your leg
in I'm just go check the truck for
boo
spit
he banging his head or
heuff okay
whatever we're going to get you
out
freak take them off take them off we're
going to get going to get Anderson was
mad at this officer and started giving
him threats inside then we'll take him
off behind me take him off we're going
to walk inside and then we'll take him
off
okay
I'm
yeah we'll take him off when we get
inside
okay are you the
one did this shit to me I have no idea
what you're talking about get the out of
here get fuck away from me well I'm your
resting get the away from me we got to
do a lot prick okay you little fing
prick okay not the first time anybody's
called me that whatever you say not
going to matter we are the little prick
just stay right here man we got to close
the door first I W go inside and I'll
take your handcuffs off off we got to go
inside get get we got to go inside
first you can take care of it if you
want but we got to get inside then I'll
take your cups off okayi that did it to
me sure can you follow me got to go
inside first well since you're twisting
your wrist that's probably why they're
tightened up on you because the way your
wrists are I make sure little let's go
inside get the out of here you stay here
you get the fuck out of here and I
guarantee you we're going to go not to
let's walk not going to fuck
yeah
little all right Doug do me a favor open
your mouth for
me I need you to open your mouth I have
to check the inside of your
mouth I'm going my God open your mouth
just like this
ah you're arrested for DUI I can't let
you go right now du from why cuz you're
drunk that's why open your
mouth I need you to
open will you do it for another officer
3162 do WR you were pulled over drunk on
the side of the
road all right I got have to redo this
very long verbatim thing or thing
verbatim it's going to ask well it's
going to say that you're under the age
of 21 school bus driver CDL driver a lot
of it won't apply to you but just hold
all questions to the end I'll answer any
questions you have at the end you'll
also get your copy of this okay
subsequent to an arrest for driving
while under the influ alcohol other drug
drugs and toxic compound compounds any
combination d section 11 41 SC of a fat
or personal injury accident you're
hereby notified that has provided in
section 11 500 vehic code you first
offender unless with the last 5 years of
this arrest for you
yeah sure are you going to fight
us you going to be cool be with the
program cuz if you are then I'll take
you out your handcuffs and then we can
make this whole situation as painless as
possible it's all going to go away okay
sure whatever you want that's what
Court's for
right thank
you
well that's because you were twisting
your look at how much space is in there
cuz they were the other way look how
much space is there cuz you twisted your
wrist the wrong
way sit down
please all right so I need you to sign
right here you're not emitting guilt or
anything like that just saying that I
have read this and explained it to you
that's all that's saying
okay can you sit down and sign this for
meone calls I have a pen for
you you know what I'm talking
about
um okay are you going to sign this or no
[Music]
you'll get your own copy of this
too what are you
doing
Che all you have to do is sign right
there just saying that I read to you and
explain it to
you you'll get your own copy of this
I'll tear it off once I fill it out
complete you and you can read your own
copy but basically in about 20 minutes
I'm going to ask you to subit to a
breast
sample sit down I'm going to charge you
with obstructing do you
understand biggest jerle take this is
all just to confirm you refusing to
provide a breath sample at this
time that's your statement yep I'm going
to press R for
refusal that's what you
want
you're refusing breath
SLE you go ahead and take a seat back
where you were all actually this officer
is going to take fingerprints and
photographs for
you all right need to stand over there
one more time you're going to be cool if
I take the cups off you correct
yes
come around the side of the counter for
me
man just stand right in front of that
door stop for
me got to take four pictures of
you you need to put your back to that
wall right there that little black
button on the
wall all
right you take four
pictures and you stand up straight
no hands down your side
no I'm fuck do I'm G fucking
right all right you're not GNA do this
we're going to put you back in
handcuffs all right need you to hold
this all right we're going to handcuff
this and take you PES to your chest if
that's what we're we need to do do
that hold this seriously
yes just for our record I need you to
hold it to your chest and and look at
the
camera okay hold it to your
chest
dog you don't do this you're going to
the county jail T night and you're not
getting bonded out okay I'm going to
prison do you understand okay hold it to
your chest my
kid I do
this if
I hey Doug this is just a photograph it
doesn't go anywhere all right you want
to back yeah yeah I've done this last
time yeah ba me out that's what happens
you're going to get a chance to bail out
but we got we got to finish the booking
process you know what happens after
that then you go
home
can you turn your head for
me you
done you st me like that stand back okay
now put your hands behind your
back your
back
and find your back I know you're F to do
that well you don't push my officers you
don't push me you don't step at me when
I tell you get get against the wall I
did get out
of all
right told
you I can't do from here there I got
told
you make this 10 times worse
than you made it 10 times worse
than
[Applause]
all right I'm back oh good
all
we transfer over the module or module we
made okay that's
fine we don't have fingerprints though
so okay that's
fine there fingerprints
everywhere I don't know maybe 100
bucks other was like
$700 know he took like fucking
$400 also he took a
dollar
according to
him
so 46 days from right now your driver's
license will be suspended for
DUI my recommendation for you is to not
drive your vehicle while your license is
suspended for DUI if you were caught
driving your vehicle driving with your
license suspended then your vehicle will
be seized per assd forfeiture and that
vehicle becomes ours you'll never get it
back that's it if you get caught driving
when your license suspended that is
you're in the wrong that is let me go 46
days from
now so you do have a right to a hearing
to send your suspension SL reifications
basically a civil hearing um to see if
you'll appear from a judge I have
attorney and yeah so your attorney will
know everything about okay I'm not
letting go you're you're here on a
here's my Pro basically a short synopsis
pull me over reason I didn't pull you
over anyway you passed out in your car
doesn't matter
so anyway this is a brief synopsis of my
proba call to rest my autograph and uh
police department date is on there that
is store
cop this is your s your own Citation for
driving on the influence of alcohol is
your personal information up here date
and time of the incident vehicle
information location of violation which
found you that violation of driving
under any influence of alcohol these are
just weather conditions here's the
report number I amended the citation CU
you originally we were going to Poston
before you decided to shove one of my
officers
so all right without a minut I need you
to sign right here you're not goy with
the conditions of the citation look at
that you hand up to the front there's a
pen right there you can sign right here
you're not ghost conditions citation
which is means show up to your cour and
not drive
intoxicated you let me go no you're in
jail you shove the police officer and
you were driving drunk so wasn't driving
drunk it wasn't driv we're driving drunk
and you just shov one my offic so I have
do what you believe okay are you going
to sign this or no how can I get out of
here you can spend the night in jail and
in front of a judge what court on Monday
're probably tomorrow or tomorrow cool
you he in front of a judge tomorrow
morning or I have no
idea there's only two of
them so are you going to sign us or not
it I can't get out of here now no I need
to get out of here now you
can't that is not up to me you already
made that decision you solely made that
decision we were going to you were going
to post your bond and you were going to
go home tonight but you decided to shove
him oh my God so don't give me that
bullshit do you not remember that sh
yeah that's a
felony if I was really I'm put refuse I
asked you several times you're
not I have two
girls
I need to okay 10 a.m. tomorrow
morning thought about earlier